this is a production of Cornell
University
I'm gonna talk a little fast because
there's a lot of stuff I want to go over
I'm from the state of Minnesota crazy
place the only place to elect a
professional wrestler as governor its
governor how many places do that some
things about Minnesota second largest
variation in temperature in the
continental US thirty-eight c2 - 53 C
90,000 miles of shoreline more than
California Florida Hawaiian combined we
measure every puddle the largest
population of people of Scandinavian
Somali among this sent outside of those
countries so we are somewhat diverse I'm
at the great University of Minnesota
55,000 undergraduates it's big school
home of Norman Borlaug won the Nobel
Peace Prize Honey Crisp apples from Jim
Looby in my department something
happened oh and where they discovered
the pacemaker which is that strange
machine down on the bottom
Medtronic spun off of largest city is
the city of Minneapolis Minnesota a
couple million people and Minneapolis
has a park board I'm chair of the park
board the park board existed before the
city of Minneapolis and so I helped run
a park system with 183 parks and 50
recreation centers 1,800 kids sports
teams I have my own police force which
is something six thousand seven hundred
and thirty two acres of land and natural
area that we manage and there's a bunch
of other statistics I'm not going to
talk about that now but I do know there
are some people who are interested in
urban agriculture
I'm instead gonna talk about plants and
stresses in plants now some changes that
have happened since the 60s why did I
even get into this area the crops we
grow in the 60s which is the last time a
lot of work in co2 photosynthesis and
some of that work in flora culture was
done it's changed the industry was cut
flowers and potted plants now the
industry is based on bedding plants and
the number of species we grow is
increased dramatically energy costs have
increased and profit margins have
decreased dramatically in the industry
we now have HBS and LED lighting which
was not as commonplace back then and we
have shade curtains and environmental
control computers but we don't have
information
put in them and temperature and co2
levels have increased when I was in
graduate school with Marvin the standard
was three hundred and thirty three parts
per million
right now it's three hundred and eighty
eight so there is little to no
information on lighting temperature and
co2 standards for the current crops we
grow even the geraniums we grow now are
different than the geraniums that were
grown in the 60s and 70s and we don't
have any information to utilize this
fantastic equipment that we have that
run our greenhouses I also want to talk
about a little bit how we stress our
plants out on a regular basis and often
don't appreciate it we have cool season
crops and more see warm season crops and
this is a relative growth rate curve of
two kinds of turf but notice with cool
season crops and I'll show you data to
this effect 20 degrees there's a maximum
see and notice above 20 degrees you
actually start having a decline and I'll
start showing that with photosynthesis
and development rate on some common
crops we grow I think we stress our
plants out commonly and have no
appreciation than we are in fact doing
that I'll show some evidence of that I'm
going to talk about abiotic stresses is
Neil mentioned I'm going talk about
light temperature and co2 I'm going to
talk a little bit about biotic stresses
and then I work in a variety of other
areas and I just want to give you a
little bit of an idea what some of those
are this is some data of the average
daily light integral or moles of light
per day in January throughout the United
States and you can see that you as
Minnesota is at two to four and at most
six moles of light and that there are
parts of the United States that benefit
greatly from adding supplemental
lighting and you can see the Cornell is
in there as well as Minnesota why do we
light well when we do light there's some
benefits here we have a graph of daily
light integral and this is cutting yield
per pot this is for taking cuttings off
of a pot stock plants and we can see
that as the daily light integral goes up
the cutting yield goes up and we can
also see with two different levels of
co2 the yield goes up but in generally
yield of any crop via tomatoes
greenhouse peppers lettuce dry weight is
proportionately increases with
photosynthesis this is actually a
picture from knee life
thank isn't it yeah you recognize that
picture you uh took this picture a long
time ago there's there's a purple wave
petunia with my the interruption
lighting and this is supplemented with
150 micro mol of additional hype HPS
light and this is just to demonstrate
both of these have long days but which
one flower is quicker the one with the
higher light level or par says standard
photosynthesis curve that's been used
for ever in a day basically shows that
as absorb light or par goes up co2
assimilation goes up there's some region
that's typically in the winter in our
area where plants are light limited but
once you get up to a certain level which
is typically around four to six hundred
micro mol saturation occurs and the
plant photosynthesis is co2 limited so
we started collecting data we use a
light core 6400 we did 25 different
species so we have huge data sets I'm
just going to show you some brief ones
to make some points this is impatience
you can see their impatience
Pargo as power goes up PN goes up until
you reach or approximately 400 micro mol
of light okay now you'll see some
standard deviations - what we do is we
take five different plants so each each
one is its five separate curves from
five separate leaves and then that's
replicated again three times over time
one horizontal leaf so we use a light
core 6400 which clamps right on yep and
I'll come back to some something related
to that question a little bit this is
I'm from a tomato grower this is bushel
boy Tomatoes they each of these
represents a different cultivar I just
want to show that within a species even
within a single greenhouse you can have
very different rates of photosynthesis
and you can have saturation occurring at
different spots this is 750 micro mole
so it's higher than the impatience and
notice that this particular cultivar o
is still increasing
so there's dramatically different
responses to increasing light suggesting
that even within the same greenhouse
there should be different light
management strategies based on the
cultivar that's used
in addition we looked at some leaf
filtering and this has not been
considered really but here's coleus and
here's panicum a grass and a col use and
then we just measured light intensity as
you move down through the canopy showing
that you have significant filtering now
these plants were just barely touching
okay but this just goes to show you that
only 60% of the incident light in a
coleus canopy actually gets to the
middle of the plant and by the time you
get to the bottom of the plant you're
down to 18% of them of irradiance that
actually can penetrate and contrast of
course with the grass it's better eighty
percent and fifty five percent and then
we shade we have these shade curtain
systems you have them in your greenhouse
but how do we decide when to close the
shade who decides bill who decides you
divine it we divide it there's no
information with which to use to
identify when we do this now I'll tell
you that most greenhouses use a standard
of three to four thousand foot camels
which is comparable to around 600 to 800
Micro Mall and then this shade system
starts closing also in our systems that
we have if you got to your greenhouses
the light sensors that control the shade
systems where does where are they
they're on a weather station that's on
outside of the greenhouse okay in
general only 60 percent of incident
light enters the greenhouse you have
more than that because you have single
pane glass and a lot of your greenhouses
most places have exa light or double
poly or another kind of poly that
diffuses the light Sears is actually
better and the shape cloth systems
typically the standard shade cloth is
55% light reduction curtain that comes
across therefore if it if use a typical
shade system with 55% when it closes at
600 micromo of light okay gradients at
the top of the canopy after getting into
the greenhouse and going through a shade
system is all the way reduced to 198
micromoles and that's at the top of the
plant and if you go to the middle of the
plant and a typical coleus canopy you're
down to a
all the way down to a third of the
actual light that comes in to look at an
impatience curve at 600 this is where
you're at getting into the greenhouse
and and the shade cloth system closed
and then this is halfway down on the
canopy down to 119 you've reduced your
photosynthesis in that particular
instance from close to seven okay all
the way down to just above to a third of
the photosynthesis you've effectively
starved your plant at that point and
greenhouses are routinely doing this
that they're over shading all the time
which is creating significant problems
that they're not aware of so for
instance in a row cut rose greenhouse or
a greenhouse vetch to facility they have
more blind shoots at the in those
facilities with roses and they have less
fertile flowers with tomatoes and the
whole problem was because of the shade
system because they did weren't using
good numbers on the shade system the
solution first of all is quite simple
take the meter that runs the system take
it off the top of the pole outside of
the greenhouse and move it into the
greenhouse into the middle of the canopy
where the plants are growing it's not
too complicated okay it's very simple
and straightforward reset the figure you
can but the problem is this that during
you know we're in the north and the Sun
comes up and up here it comes up and
Minneapolis it gets up 23 degrees above
the horizon on Christmas and then goes
back down again when the light barely
comes up like that more skips off the
glass and so still this so in other
words the what gets in the greenhouse
changes depending on the sun angle so
simply the best thing is just put it in
the greenhouse which none of the
greenhouse companies do and which
actually absolutely would be the best
thing for all of you to do and then run
the chain system off that that works for
any greenhouse I don't know if a single
greenhouse in the United States that has
the light sensor for the plants are okay
witching topics the temperature the
world is a warm place and it's getting
warmer okay it's a premise that I work
off of I work in a lot of heat stress we
are routinely causing heat stress in our
crops most of us don't appreciate that
now plants naturally try to do things
they'll reflect light as best they can
in warm places but we often will stress
many of our crops bushel by tomatoes
which is a large large greenhouse tomato
producer their lowest yield is the
summer which is not what you would
expect but that's when the yield is the
lowest why is it the lowest when we
started this research project because of
them it's simply because of heat stress
that occurs on tomatoes the species
differ in the optimal temperature for
photosynthesis and that optimal
temperature can actually change as the
season progresses okay it's my belief
that we retune routinely reducing
photosynthesis by growing plants to warm
I'll show you some examples here's a
curve this is pansy temperatures see
there's three light levels three hundred
six hundred and nine hundred micro moles
and here's P N and you can see the pansy
PN is optimal at 20 C okay you can also
see that as you go above 20 degrees C
which the greenhouses probably are even
today that photosynthesis starts to
decline and you can see this on the
plants there's two plants and sorry for
it's in Fahrenheit there's constant 20 C
on the left and you have 30 C on the
right you can pretty clearly see the 30
C pansy has less photosynthesis that
it's occurred with that crop there's a
group of crops that I would say our mid
range this is gerbera and you can see it
is an optimal temperature between 20 and
25 and then you can see a shift so
further with poinsettia where you'll
have an optimal temperature with
poinsettia around 30 degrees C and this
is why we can raise poinsettia stock
plants in a greenhouse during the summer
but a question we started asking is why
or what is the justification or cause
these responses for these curves to
shift because the photochemistry should
be essentially the same we started
looking at the stomachs and just plain
old stomata conductance and stomata
behavior and if you remember the pansy
plot this is actually temperature versus
to model conductance you can see it's
quite high and as temperature increase
the Stowe mates actually closed the
limitation that occurred with
photosynthesis may be associated with
closure of Stowe mains okay if we look
at gerbera I look at this tomato
conductance with gerbera we can see that
we also had here was a round where we
had the optimal temperature and then you
can see the decline again suggesting
that frankly if this donates clothes of
course the plant is going to have less
photosynthesis and that may be part of
the justification for that something
else we looked at a short-term high
temperature okay what we found was that
a short-term innum by what short-term
two hours okay now we focus on
temperatures that are not temperatures
that people would call heat shock
there's lots of research on heat shock
and that typically is at temperatures of
40 to 45 C we're looking at temperatures
that are 30 to 40 that plants see on a
very common basis in a greenhouse well
we asked the question if we let the
temperatures heat up to 95 degrees
Fahrenheit for two hours was there any
impact on a plant and there was this is
a graph of par on the bottom versus PN
and you can see the typical curve right
here but look at what happened if the
plants were exposed the two hours a 35 C
and we redid the curve we had a fully a
59 percent reduction in the maximum
photosynthesis the plant could do we
went back in the next day and measured
again we were still depressed the next
day it came up it took three days three
days for the plant three
from that single 95 degree exposure we
worked on some other crops this is
petunia this is Cole Avenue shades we
saw the same response significant
depression and three days to come back
up
so these short-term high temperature
exposures can have a long a three day or
more effect growers are in fact doing
this why because they want to save money
they let their greenhouse temperatures
increase at the end of the day to
capture heat and keep the greenhouse
closed hoping that they'll keep the heat
moving into the night now the Israelis
it didn't have done some work with this
actually as well they did work with
field Tomatoes and part of the they saw
the midday depression in photosynthesis
that often occurs and so what they did
is a irrigated the field tomatoes and
cooled the leaves when the leaves got
really hot at that one time of the day
and they've found the significant they
got a significant increase in yield as a
result of that and it eliminated the
midday depression of photosynthesis that
occurred from that high temperature I
wonder if we could apply some of these
concepts in greenhouses as well or
greenhouse tomato production essentially
anytime the temperature exceeds the
maximum you should do whatever you can
to try to reduce the temperature to the
optimal temperature range I'll mention
one other thing we called around then we
started looking for what are their
fundamental differences between heat
tolerant plants with respect to
flowering and heat intolerant so what we
did is we called companies that produce
flowers bedding plants of different
kinds send us a geranium that's very
heat tolerant and send us a geranium
that's very heat intolerant and then we
did photosynthetic response curves and
in every case and these are across
companies and across species in every
case the heat tolerant plant which is in
red always had a higher photosynthetic
rate than the heat intolerant plant
suggesting that there may be some
association with heat tolerance as well
I never brings to mind we did some work
on some rabbit opposites as well
everyone worked on rabbit opps it's at
one point or another and what we did is
we looked at how different kinds of heat
stresses we did one hour two hour for
our eight hours sixteen hour how these
different stresses at different
temperatures so we've imposed all
different kind of stress because the
term stress is a difficult term to
define Kazu because how do we define it
you know what is it is that eight hours
at 28 degrees or one hour at 36 degrees
and what we found is a very strange
relationship and this is we published
this back in 2005 and we looked at these
are we evaluated a number of different
arab adopts as strains but what we did
is we put it onto a degree day model and
the data fit almost too close it's one
of these situations where the graduate
student comes back and gives you
something and you think they had to
let's move to points but you can see
these points fit the models and what
this was was this is the data suggested
there was a cumulative effect of these
different stresses okay with a degree
our concept over 32 degrees okay and
that for whatever reason when we
exceeded 225 degree hours okay over 32
degrees you could see that we went from
no abortion to completely aborting all
the flowers on a rabbit OPS's we don't
understand this but it didn't matter how
the stresses were arranged in other
words of a 38 degree stress for three
hours or 34 degrees for more time it was
the cumulative effect in degree hours
over 32 degrees
so taken together if you look at the
stomata conductance stuff we have it
brings to mind a couple questions do
some plants either produce more ABA okay
there's plants that were heat sensitive
did they produce more a B in response to
a chronic chronic high temperature
stress or are they more responsive to
the high temperature stress to the same
endogenous ABA level because the
responses were seeing time and time
again are related to stomata closure not
any damage to the photosystem in the
temperature range I'm talking about okay
okay ken stomatal conductance after a
single stress be a way that we can
screen for heat tolerance because after
a heat stress even a two-hour heat
stress if the student still mates are
staying open and the plant is still
actively photosynthesizing it likely is
going to be more heat tolerant than one
that is not so here's a screen protocol
it can be used co2 we went back and
start looking at co2 all the greenhouses
in the United States people who've been
around for a while remember there used
to be co2 burners in greenhouses we got
away from them because the burners would
not work properly and they'd release
ethylene you have disasters and so
people got away from using co2 burners
so if you go around to greenhouses now
in flora culture there's next to no co2
being used
here's cyclamen down here is ambient all
the way down here look at the degree of
responsiveness that you can get on
cyclamen by increasing co2
here's greenhouse Tomatoes now this
particular grower is the greenhouse
tomato growers and greenhouse vegetable
growers do inject co2 typically up to
800 parts per million so you can see
that's here and some of these species
still would benefit but the bottom line
is there is huge huge responses to co2
more than what we appreciate we went
into the research greenhouses and looked
at what are our co2 levels on a sunny
day and
the meter reading 193 parts per million
193 parts per million
weird the co2 go the plants used it up
the new greenhouses we have we've spent
so much effort in time making them tight
that the co2 levels in the greenhouses
are actually significantly depleted
significantly depleted and we don't even
really appreciate this to give you an
idea this is one hour under considered
low light medium light and high light
started at 388 one hour in a low light
greenhouse the rate the co2 level
dropped at 370 one hour and medium light
down the 341 hour and highlight all the
way down to 310 in one hour and then
single hour okay now I can tell you if
you have all kinds of high pressure
sodium lights up there after 2-3 hours
your plants if they're down to 190 parts
per million they're not using all that
light you're simply wasting the light
the new open roof greenhouses that
people recognize gives you superior
growth in the industry part of the
reason I believe is frankly that these
have co2 levels that are similar to
ambient co2 and they're not co2 depleted
the addition of co2 is the number one
most cost-effective way to actually
increase photosynthesis in a greenhouse
today not all the lighting it's number
one if I take a co2 sensor and go into a
canopy on a bench on any of your
canopies okay you'll check and you'll
find that your co2 level inside that
canopy is often around two to three
hundred parts per million okay even when
the greenhouse is venting because you
can't get this boundary layer that's
correct
that forms on the bench itself in some
cases doing nothing more than
circulating your air at least equalizes
as a co2 level within the greenhouse so
you don't have depletion within a canopy
at least you'll get up to 380 if you're
bringing in air from outside and I think
in our experimental greenhouses and in
our growth chambers we are commonly
depleting or growing plants and depleted
two levels that are actually
dramatically affecting our results and
in some cases invalidating them because
the plant may not even be able to use
the light that you're providing in the
growth chamber itself switch gears a
little bit with succulents there's a lot
of interest in succulents this is just a
show this is a crown of thorns and
succulents respond as other plants to
increasing co2 this is during the day
now there are plants is this is s
Chavarria and a o Neum these take up co2
at night not all what we consider the
camp plants actually do take up co2 at
night we studied a number of cacti and
they're taking up co2 during the day in
many cases the assumption is that
they're only taking co2 up at night and
that's not the case
also orchids Phalaenopsis orchids will
take up co2 during the day but this is
[ __ ] rope frag poppy diem and this is the
beginning of the night and this is co2
uptake and you can see pretty clearly
that this orchid takes up co2 at night
only suggesting if you're producing this
orchid that you should actually be
injecting co2 at night so there's
differences and move along quick high
temperatures slowing of development rate
leaf unfolding rate this is an old graph
of views from African violets follows
this standard line so this is pretty
common curve for lots of plants we have
we have an optimal temperature and
frankly leaf unfolding rate often is
optimized around right around 85 degrees
Celsius and this was developed here's
african violet you can see leaf number
increasing up to here and then you can
see a decrease and this is what I want
to focus on because we have decreases
this for whatever reason this
temperatures almost Sentinel to lots of
things this is melon fly egg development
and doesn't it look out an awful lot
like the graph we just saw but my point
is this when the temperature exceeds the
Optima which in greenhouse production it
commonly does we actually slow the rate
of leaf unfolding and slow the crop down
in
development rate okay these hot
temperatures and right now your leaf
temperatures remember one thing if it's
85 degrees in the greenhouse your leaf
temperature is above 90 and approaching
95 you were actually on the other end of
that curve and your crop is actually
starting to slow it'll take longer to
flower its underappreciated area using
the standard curve if we go from 85 to
95 that same plant to unfold one leaf
will now take five days instead of three
point three you've slowed leaf unfolding
approximately by a third so to come back
again we have a number of crops that are
down in this area and we have
temperatures that are routinely going
from 20 up to 35 C and we were routinely
decreasing photosynthesis as part of
that process and we're routinely
decreasing the leaf unfolding rate and
actually slowing the crop development in
that process and we are routinely
closing our stomata and someone was
talking about edge burn on lettuce well
the high temperature is encouraging LEDs
burn on lettuce you can kind of
understand where that comes from if the
still mates are closing of course the
plant is going to have difficulty taking
up calcium in that scenario now we've
gone through all different kinds of
crops I'm not going to go through this
and identified what happens if you
decrease temperatures and timing of that
and then we've integrated that into a
package that everyone has access to and
if you if any of you haven't tried this
program it's a wonderful programs called
virtual grower it's free for everyone
USDA has it it's used for modeling crop
growth temperature you can literally
take your greenhouse and identify how
much more it's going to cost if you
switch the outer covering on the
greenhouse or not so that's how we
pulled together the last thing is biotic
stresses I think most of us appreciate
that when a plant is attacked it
releases volatiles that go to other
plants sometimes within the same species
sometimes other species and tell that
plant that's being attacked plants
communicate via volatiles there's a
plant this is from data that is not mine
from 2001 this is
illness son infested and here's an
illness that is infested here's the GC
depicting the dramatic expression
variety of volatiles that are produced
after infestation there's also a recent
picture just showing you the degree to
the sophistication this is a recent
paper so the insect lays an egg this is
on a rabbit ops Asst that egg actually
produces a compound that stimulates
salicylic acid which isn't agonistic to
jazz monic acid okay so this actually
creates a system where the plant is not
able to defend itself so when the larvae
does hatch the plant doesn't know it's
being attacked and is defenseless
started looking at what happens if we
expose plants to methyl Jasmine ate one
of the primary volatiles that plants
give off to warn that an attack has been
made what we did is we would treat
plants okay with methyl Jasmine 8 and
then we would have fest them with mites
okay and this is how many mites fled led
the plants okay so you'll see that in
each case a plant that was exposed to
methyl Jasmine eight okay and this was
for a single hour resulted in a plant
that when you would put mites on it the
mites would flee okay compared to the
control also if we quite quantified if
we come back to the tomato you'll notice
the tomato had significant effect if we
look at we quantify Proteus inhibitors
which is one of the purported responses
that plants have a methyl in response to
methyl jasmit you'll see whether that
was tomato that as methyl Jasmine II
concentration went up or exposure went
up the plant produce more protease
inhibitor in response to that if we take
that further this is the number of mites
that were on the plant okay after a
period of three weeks you can see that
in any case whenever there was a plant
that was exposed to methyl Jasmine it
had fewer mites
that was the same case for aphids notice
the control we had 22 this is after 11
days with aphids 22 aphids we had methyl
salicylate but notice methyl Jasmine 8
we had a fraction of that we had 8 in
that case it's just representation of
some of the work that we have but
clearly in all the studies we did after
plant was exposed to methyl Jasmine 8 it
actually not only did the plants or
insects try to flee it but they actually
proliferated less now predation of any
kind and activation of plant defenses
has a cost for plants and so actually
when you turn on plant defenses that
plant will actually have less dry weight
than a plant adjacent to it if the
defenses are turned on the plant is
spending a lot of effort actually
producing compounds to defend itself at
the expense of other materials so
there's a cost to this and something
that's also very interesting is that if
you look at different kinds of wounding
responses you'll only see a response
okay to a caterpillar not a tearing
saying that somehow the plant recognizes
a pest I don't know why this is blurred
on this one okay but the bottom line is
FAC is actually caterpillar spit okay
the plant actually perceives the saliva
from the caterpillar and that's what
causes the chain reaction in a response
it's very very specific so we're in the
process right now of actually
determining whether plants have
vocabulary because I think that the
response to a white fly may be different
than 1/8 and which may be different than
a mite so we're looking at those areas
I'll be very brief new directions we're
doing a lot of new crop work this is
what South Africa this gives you an idea
of some the gladiolas that exist in
South Africa we do very have very little
gladiolus species in the United States
we're doing work with cactus and
succulents where we think that they can
be new bedding plants or new potted
plants and we've been identifying plants
and protocols to get cacti and
succulents to flower when we want them
to so you can have them bloom
all year doing the same with succulents
of different kinds and we identify
protocols you can pretty clearly see
there when footed period exceeds 12
hours with all those species these are
each clan shows that they remain
vegetative that if the photo period is
less than 13 hours their reproductive
we've done a large project on green
roofs in the Midwest because the green
roof work that's been done in Baltimore
and the east coast in Chicago and
Toronto doesn't apply to the Midwest so
we screened 78 species over a series of
years and identified what plants will
survive on a green roof in the Midwest
work it's a crazy project undrafted
cactus okay someone say there aren't
many grafted cactus you're wrong there's
a lot of grafted cactus in the world
okay each of these cacti is on a
different root stock it's the same Scion
so the effect you see is purely a
rootstock response here's a lot of it a
lot of potential for this as far as
expanding the crop palate there is some
interest in aquaponics I will just
mention a couple things there's a little
difficult area we talked this morning
about how you have to optimize you have
to optimize the fish number that will
survive you have to optimize how many
plants a fish can fish population can
support and then as the plants grow the
conditions that you have changes and the
market you know people are getting tired
of tilapia there's only so much tilapia
you can eat right okay so and we think
like we have the Schlitz brewery is
converting into a giant aquaculture
facility in Minneapolis they're gonna be
producing more tilapia than we know what
to do it the interest in our growers is
frankly an alternative aqua ponic crops
and so what's an alternative crop this
is what's called a red cloth which it
has no red claw it has a blue cloth I
don't know why they call it red claw but
it's a large freshwater Lobster it's
actually a crayfish that gets a really
big tail from Thailand shrimp crabs and
freshwater oysters there's a lot more
interest in this and the restaurants in
the Minneapolis area are very interested
in this
and there are some that have some of
these crazy systems where their fish at
the bottom this is LEDs in the center
okay and this is lettuce in this case
but actually they've switched to basal
and this rotates okay my question was
why why not just great they grow basil
in the greenhouse someplace
it'd be a lot cheaper but they they
effectively do this and so it works and
the last picture is this contraption
which is actually in California from two
weeks ago and someone has to identify
protocols for these guys this is Tom and
Jerry
so tom and jerry work and they see each
other so they don't ever smash into each
other and what they're doing is they're
spacing plants so those guys will work
for six hours
okay and then you put a new battery pack
in and then need to keep going there's
no overtime there's no health care
there's no there's no complaints but
someone has to program this thing about
what a plant looks like and what to do
and there's actually a project we're
looking at this is a these little
helicopters with a little tank of
pesticide and the helicopters will fly
they will recognize an aphid and then
spritz it and the intent is to use it in
order to so that these things will
target target the shoot tips so so in
Minnesota none of the water flows it all
just sits like this in these big
mosquito poulsen but this is land I have
but anyway I'll answer any questions you
may have I supposed to get done by one
and I am done 20 seconds early
yes in some of your early slides you
showed photo opportunity you showed
stomata conductance data the like or
also calculated CI internal co2 what did
that look like and are stowe mates
actually optimizing their conductance to
maintain a constant C I so that they're
not a question we didn't find out that
we didn't find that easily and the other
thing I wonder about is you know that as
you increase co2 to examine tomato
greenhouse or something miss Timmy's
actually closed down it gets smaller to
accommodate some of which they're
talking about but I don't know what
impact that has on the actual
photosynthesis I still believe that
there's a decrease and the short-term
eat stress we saw that lag seems to
support them there is a some sort of
response to the plant has that some of
these plants are responding to something
and I assume it's indicating so so nice
that would be actually to look at
some units India needs to look and see
what her response happens within the
communities themselves but as far as in
terms of CI we didn't find the
optimization or trying to get the
constant internal yes we use the legwork
yes could the differences the internals
see I explained why you were seeing
difficult right response occurs in the
standard for Thursday which could the
differences in the internal CIA the
explaining why we're getting different
light response curves where you have
power verses of p.m. but the same you
mean within writing being the same
species different right I don't know I'd
have to look I mean they're seeing there
clearly is inherent differences probably
from you know from the parentage of
these different pulse cars that imposed
the maximum rate that can occur so I
assume it's related to the parentage
because if you take a group of species
you'll find within that group of species
within the genus that'll be different
maximum
to make any sense yeah
we need to do that so what you showed
seemed to responses are for synthetic
response yet and for parallel
accentuated throughout the temperature
range
so there must be something wasn't just
at each shot down that was occurring for
the resistant versus
yeah they were parallel our yes
Oh
yeah with the liquor we actually you can
set us a specific humidity level and
maintain your bacon crunchy that's it
you know so if you've been set it so
that it doesn't confounding
in fashion
yeah there is there's very much pressure
deficit that actually comedies like we
know we didn't measure ABA the
assumption is because we're seeing the
guard cells cloaker you know closure of
the stomachs at a VA somehow on top of
the process but there's no evidence to
confirm and also a little infection and
for keeping us on see a bus bus or
something we didn't look we didn't look
for nutrient deficiencies they were
treated the same when the responses were
that you saw almost immediate some cases
another question related to the eating
she confides growers it's a always so I
agree knows and so what you tell them
now okay eat is bad but cheating is also
bad so what should they be do you know
with the tomato green house and the Rose
green Isles this started with gross
preamble we tell them to shut the shades
isn't down and when they shut the shade
system down guess what happens to the
blind shooting percentage in the summer
dramatically dropped and the blind
shoots think we're having they weren't
having so it solve a problem well that
no not let's just put it this way they
eat problem with the clients wasn't as
bad as the shade problem okay the shade
was more limiting than high temperature
reduction okay
very Curt yeah
so an app grows that shows them the
requestors but the shade where you saw I
think just in one example within
patients that have dropped labels down
to
what about the period of light exposure
no love life highlight because both my
hands when he was here it's all pain
that you know I put the shade over five
o'clock of lettuces because otherwise
they had too much light but the period
of the photosynthesis was too long to me
this didn't make sense but that's what
he claimed now do you think that was the
time for photosynthesis or was he and I
currently the temperature he's how he
did they think so have you done any
experiments with the area no I have not
we haven't done that and I don't see a
rationale for it oh I didn't miss the
rationality
5bn what where there is a stress that I
think occurs on crops that we don't
appreciate is actually anymore you might
be aware of work done with person taken
prisoner in that case it's actually
damage to the person that I have read us
we need that bright light and cool
temperatures in England in fact they
were able to tribute weather the corn
crop maybe it or not its associated with
how many cool bright mornings they had
there's actually clear clothes that they
damage at the University of Essex I
don't know how often that occurs in our
crops and we typically don't let our
crops get cold but in some locations
they do and that actually causes
suppression long term suppression as
well full of right when we do our
temperature drop for a stem elongation
I think the yellowing MVC is actually
bankable
damaged with verses
okay wanted to take the messages I got
from your talk is that a greenhouse
while it's a controlled environment it's
still in perfect place to grow a plant
subscribe to do a lot more optimize
carbon dioxide optimized like device
and then at the end of your talk you
should interesting slide of this
rotating drum implant which i think is
pretty unrealistic but maybe maybe it's
not so unrealistic think about factory
warehouse growing if you could optimize
wolf I've worked on this for a while
right we come out as interested in this
for quite some time and I think it is
possible to do it's just whether it's a
cost-efficient
the first thing I would do frankly and
we're in the process of doing this at
the University now this room is warm and
it's comfortable because the thermostat
for all of us is right here okay the
first thing is to take the light sensors
and all the sensors associated with mike
brosman put them where plants are okay
then so that's the first thing I would
do is first the other thing is that I
would find out where your actual light
levels are because I bet you in the
garage here was named greenhouses you
are suppressing worth more than what you
appreciate and I think that's occurring
across the board and I think it's
occurring in both chambers as far as
factory production there are definitely
there are places that want to do factory
production but in many cases it frankly
is a lot cheaper to just do traditional
production and I don't see in the
economics to do factory production yeah
as long as you have accessible land in
Minneapolis if you drive 30 minutes
you're in open farmland you really need
to spend all the money to do an
intensive system in a factory
have an on intenser system that may be
more cost-effective
I don't need to say that this
with deficiency of Lights is everything
they can in the future of music
but you can create an optimal
environment for that moment you just
need to know what the parameters are
able to meet the question is whether
it's gonna be enough right that's that's
a separate question because what I
haven't tell me is our plants probably
could use more light
we're giving them at some point the
economic
so that it's and it's going to be
different you know frankly we just
discussed this before in New Hampshire
the cost of electricity is called an F
cents per kilowatt and Minneapolis is
three and a half cents per kilowatt hour
economics are very different for what
the co2 you had some co2 grass-like I
don't have to mention the period or the
time that was done because there are
some experiments which show that it
you've got a show to us to grow they can
listen here to Princeton all the time
there's not that much information that
it comes back that was before have you
found that in you crow said that's a
very good question the answer is is no
because frankly the basis for adding co2
to tomato great houses and they increase
in the illness because they get a
permanent increase in photosynthesis
well what we're looking at is
acclamation burst and that to our high
temperature pulse we're looking at the
who periodically whether the plant
doesn't depress but actually adapt
doing that actually
I think it's a good point planning to
acclimate
there's actually a recent paper rapid
access related to this they found that
the gravit offices did not
perfectly increased
other questions for time
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu